hello
Titan
mom
I'm Jim Halpert
let's burn on
a little comment hmm cool Ryan you're so
smart you're smarter than Mark
Zuckerberg and those Google guys all
combined
you're so ignorant you barely know what
you're talking about
so ridiculous you really need to read a
couple books what's a book oh my God
you're so embarrassed
I'm pretty good on politics
California is bankrupt and California
California
you talking to me
but
you stay
where's my steak
big Meryl Streep fan so I shouldn't be
surprised that he's identified with her
character
did me Armani
suit on the phone like the main company
number because I'm gonna have to call
information where's Armani he's on the
phone too slow you're not going to Paris
I'm so much better than you
I I'm could you just let me every time
every time black people want to have a
good time some English
[Laughter]
I always want credit for something
stupid
what you want cookie
[Music]
[Laughter]
no oh no stop oh no yes take my ride
okay seriously
okay okay
yes I have a wig for every single person
in the office
you never know when you're going to need
to Bear a passing resemblance to someone
and I am back how'd it go no no Pam I'm
back for good
Kevin Neal
[Applause]
it's kind of blurry
it's better
question what kind of bear is best
it's a ridiculous question false black
bear well that's debatable there are
basically two schools of thought fact
bears eat beets oh bears beats
Battlestar Galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses uh four dollars
and it only cost me seven dollars to
recreate the rest of the Ensemble and
that's a grand total of
eleven dollars
you know what imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery so I thank you
it's not a joke Jim
millions of families suffer every year
Michael
oh that's funny Michael
Howard like uh mohauer who's Huges yep
watch this this is Mo
ah right here three series high five oh
Pam it's a guy thing Pam I'm sort of a
student of Comedy
watches
[Music]
I'm Hitler
the name is Barn Santa Bond all of an
eggnog she could not start
classic Brosnan hey can you help me find
Michael Scott Angela my boyfriend can
he's a state senator oh no he can't help
because that title has no meaning
he'll be able to help
Jim
do you know where I can find Michael
Scott oh I totally don't know where
Michael is dude hey you want to listen
to some records no one's listening to me
I'm running out of time what are you
talking about
I can't get up my name is
he did the voice it's a little
derivative
the parody is always derivative it's not
organic do you know what I mean Jim does
a really good one do yours oh guys you
know I really refuse to participate
Michael can I have an advance on my
paycheck because I miss his field cookie
just opened up at the mall because when
we leave the parodies to the pros at Man
TV sorry Gabe but that show hasn't been
on it many cookies
don't ever touch the black man radio
let's talk hard it's my shower
I won't touch yours by the way
I think the main difference between me
and Donald Trump
is that I get no pleasure out of saying
the words you're fired
you foliated your food
he just makes people sad and an office
can't function that way
no way you're fired
I think if I had a catchphrase it would
be you're hired and you can work here as
long as you want
but that's unrealistic so
uh Spock are there any signs of life
down there well let me check captain
[Music]
no Captain no signs of life down here
just a wet blanket named Pam
Star Trek
morning Dwight
who are you
who am I
I'm Jim we've been working together for
12 years
we're judged White
you're not Jim Jim's not Asian you
seriously never noticed hey hats off to
you for not seeing race
all right then Jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
uh Wellington systems sought them 10
cases of 24 pound letter stock or were
you talking about Creek or Murphy
because I didn't close that one yet but
I'm hoping I've got a voicemail from
Paul Krieger waiting for me
complete enter your password
you have one new message no no no no no
that is sensitive information only for
employees not Outsiders so I cut it out
I'm trying to work you don't work here
you're not Jim Jeff
oh great can't wait
Jim's at the dentist this morning and
Steve is an actor friend of ours I don't
know who you are
not Jim
this is Jim
oh dude uh how did
hey I don't get no respect no respect at
all
when I was in the sandbox as a kid I got
no respect
my wife likes to talk after sex
so she called me from a hotel room said
I don't respect you
thoughtless
ah you know what don't get no respect
airplane food
why don't they just make the plane out
of the airline food
my wife don't get no respect
some take her please for example
if you don't get no respect you might be
redneck
respect East knife
what's the deal with grape nuts no
grapes no nuts
I don't get no respect
hey it's cool man I work in the
warehouse I'm cool I'm hip and I'm Jive
but I don't care about nobody do you
know who I am happy Halloween jerk
E.T phone Holly Holly like phone Holly
Mrs old phone why new phone is confusing
it's bad reception oh bummer bummer
Reese's Pieces Reese's Pieces oh God
please stop